[Musique]
selon la définition du petit larousse
les cheminées sont des conduits de tôle
ou de maçonnerie par où s'échappe la
fumée cette définition laconique ne dit
pas toute une nuit par an en effet les
cheminées ont une autre destination
cette nuit là elles deviennent par une
mystérieuse inversion le déversoir du
ciel et leur but essentiel n'est plus
que de faire arriver au soulier placé
devant l'âtre les cadeaux du père noël
[Musique]
et
autrefois est souvent encore dans nos
campagnes tout était simple les
cheminées où l'on mettait fumée les
jambons posséder des conduits d'air tiko
est d'une taille qui permettait le
passage d'une brouille aujourd'hui par
contre quelle différence
le peuple des cheminées est infiniment
divers étroite coude et zigzaguant
innombrables elle pour chacune leurs
problèmes et c'est cela qui complique la
tâche du père noël
il lui a donc fallu mettre à jour un
recensement d'un nouveau genre procéder
à l'étude de chaque cas disposer de
services spécialisés dont l'aspect ni
l'outillage n'appelle l'attention à
défaut d'être invisible et c'est sur ce
problème des cheminées que les
actualités françaises ont réussi à faire
interviewer le père noël par le plus
indiqué de leurs enquêteurs alemagna
utilisait pour faire arriver les jouets
dans les souliers de l'objet est
inférieur ou jamais de la chine et ses
trésors qui s'applique à la chute des
corps présentaient mais on sait aussi
qu'il possède une énergie tel qu'il
risque de se briser
il faut dont le freiner dans sa chute
problème du retour du spoutnik soit à
l'aide d'une fusée retarde attriste joue
en sens contraire
soit à l'aide d'un parachute
ralentisseurs ces deux moyens ont été
l'objet d'études très poussée
[Musique]
c'est cependant une troisième formule
qui a été choisi elle avait depuis
longtemps fait ses preuves il arrive
sans doute mais une fois sur vinyle que
le philly case ce qui explique que les
soldats de plomb compte parfois des
invalides
il ya aussi d'autres cas le plus ardu et
celui du gabarit dont le cerceau et
l'exemple pour le résoudre les services
du père noël ont mis au point un liquide
astringent d'une formule gardée secrète
mais d'une efficacité absolue
quelques coups de vaporisateurs et les
molécules se resserre à l'arrivée et la
chaleur aidant le cerceau reprendra ses
dimensions
il faut tout de même compter avec les
stocks d'astra gens leurs défauts
expliquent l'arrivée imprévue d'un petit
larousse d'une boîte de compass ou d'une
petite soeur et il faut compter aussi
avec les erreurs de dosage
[Musique]
pensez à l'immensité du problème quand
votre regard se porte sur les toits
posez vous la question ce réparateur ce
ramoneur sont-ils vrai est ce qu'il ne
serait pas plutôt des collaborateurs du
père noël
[Musique]